Hello everyone, hello, hello, welcome to Snowbreak
Containment Zone.
Before we begin, I want to say a huge shout out to snow
break and amazing season games for the sponsor for today.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Hello.
Whoa.
Hello there.
Hello nurse.
Oh look, she's welcoming us in guys.
She's also welcoming us in.
Um, but yes, you shout out to this to them for sponsoring me
today.
Um, I'm trying to, uh, I'm trying not to look because I did
look at what I have to say first then I can look anyway if
you guys want to check out the game um please look at the
guys I need it guys I have an idea guys I have to put this
on so I can focus okay all right okay all right anyway so
focus see
This is very important knowledge, okay?
This is very important info.
I need you guys to focus on this info.
If you focus on this info, I will remove the image.
Guys, if you want me to remove the image, make sure to click
the link pinned in the chat or click on the panel or even do
exclamation point snowbreak and click on the link pinned in
the chat.
And then I'll remove the sensor.
and quick guys click the link that you can see as much as
you want so um i need you guys to focus focus chat anyway um
the great thing about it is that by clicking on the link and
signing up you can get 110 free pulls and a free ssr
character and we all know we all love free stuff here guys
But you guys will click on the link, right?
You guys are going to click on the link the moment I remove
this, right?
Yeah, free stuff!
Oh my god!
Also, what else?
But yeah, the game is available on iOS, Android, and PC.
So just make sure to click on the link pinned in the chat,
or click on the panel, or even do exclamation snowbreak.
All of them works because it all links to the same thing.
Um, oh gosh, oh gosh, I think the last time I played
Snowbreak was when, I think it was when it first released,
right guys?
I remember it was also a sponsor, it was a very long time
ago, and wow, this game, wow, it has, wow, changed a lot.
It was a very long time ago, and, um, sorry, I'm like,
stutter, I'm like stammering right now, but it's,
understandable guys okay so when i first when i first booted
up the game obviously this is what i saw and i was so
confused i was like what's going on and then i asked my
manager i was like um am i allowed to remove this and then
he was like yeah yeah yeah the sponsor said it's okay to
play the uncensored version it's like i was like yabba dabba
do if they said it's okay and no one else got it let's
fucking go like i was like i'm not giddy up let's go we're
going downtown
so um huge shout out to them for letting me play the
uncensored version and huge shout out for twitch for not
banning my account question mark
so so let's let's hope on that oh oh audio guys said to
lower the bgm a little bit was it i did lower it a little
bit so everything is oh actually i'll lower it um let's see
give me a sec i'll lower the the bgm in general so let me
see where is it audio music all right audio let me know if
that's better um what else what do i want to let you guys
know about But before we begin, for those who don't know
what Snowbreak is, oh gosh, sorry, I am stammering a lot
right now.
You get, there was one thing I saw in the notes that I
really want to tell you guys about.
Snowbreak's unique and immersive 3D intimate interaction
with your waifus.
And it's also the only 3D waifu shooter in the global
market.
And I'm like, oh.
that's interesting
I was like what do they mean by that
awesome in the hour mark in the one hour mark I will be
doing a giveaway courtesy of Snowbreak for five lucky
winners and during the one hour mark and you can potentially
win uh 25 uh steam gift card so he again he showed up to
snowbreak um for the sponsor and also providing a giveaway
for the dragoons so if you can potentially win 25 you can
potentially win a free game like that more free stuff yay we
got the free stuff
yay um What else?
What else did I want to mention?
Before we ban- Before we have to play the game There are
some videos that I do have to watch I believe it's about the
new updates And everything and also some lore Some more for
us as well So Snowbrick is a 3D waifu shooter RPG designed
for casual And fun gaming play You enjoy the chill
atmosphere While interacting with girls in thrilling
shooting battles is available across multiple platforms
including pc ios android and epic yay
oh sorry there's just some audio notes before audio guy make
sure to double check uh regarding the video um about the
video so let me know if the video is too quiet or too loud i
would love i would love to oh uh oh well primarily bgm is
too loud so we will adjust that right now as well oh yes
i'll need you to help for adjusting the video as well
that'll be watching
okay just got it
all right let's go all right remember to click on the link
pin in the chat guys it does help out a lot
All right, here you go.
Agitant, stay alert.
Whoa.
Wait,
this is a...
Okay, this is an 11-minute video.
And I...
Whoa!
Or scan...
Oh, sorry.
Scan the QR code.
I forgot about the QR code.
My eyes never travel to the right.
I swear.
Oh, my God.
I just realized I forgot that I do have a QR code underneath
the chat so underneath the overlay so if you can scan that
too I I just noticed I just forgot I forgot about the QR
code
oh hey oh no she got affected by the cat Her cap genes are
taking over!
A long time now.
See?
Agitare.
Oh, yeah, there is a QR code.
Oh, is that me?
I'm so cool.
I am Chrysophus.
I have come to kill you.
Oh, my God.
Is that the bad guy?
Oh, that's what that is.
Like, it's basically a shooter.
So you can do, like, just dodges and stuff.
this during this a long time ago it's definitely a lot
different from when i first played it oh what the fuck
it's your favorite druid why is it your favorite game why if
evil why hot
that's the sound guy brought the video up a little bit
agitant
Come to the Nyanya Confession Booth.
I answer thy call.
Actually, that day, I dropped it on purpose.
Ta-da!
Boo Boo, the mage, takes the stage.
Zealot contact with me.
Wait, where did she get the stick from?
Wait a minute.
The magic spell becomes unstable.
Adjacent, can you help me replenish my magic?
Whoa!
What the?
I'm- I'm- oh my god!
Oh, guys!
Guys!
I was helping her get up!
She fell down and I helped her get up!
Give me gifts to everyone!
First, can you guess what gift I brought you?
A bell?
That's such a shitty gift!
Oh my god, this never- it's- it never is ending.
How about now?
Still ordinary Yeah, it's so shitty bill are delivered by
riding reindeer But before that can you team this one?
What of course Exclusive little reindeer guys I was I Was
wrapping gifts.
I I was wrapping gifts guys Guys,
I was just wrapping gifts, guys.
I...
I was helping her put on her shoes, guys.
I'm bald.
I know you ordered really small shoes.
You could have ordered a bigger shoe size.
oh my oh my god we're only halfway i don't know how many
more excuses i can think up of i am wow right by boo boo
side easy right yeah they need so much help guys i'm such a
good person oh i'm so helpful I just like to chase after
floaty things.
The only thing that can catch my attention is you, agitant.
Humans usually struggle to comprehend human magic.
This is the...
If you're first time chatting, remember to scan the QR code
for more fun moments like this.
Oh, no, outfits.
It's like, look, you are good.
Oh, it's nice that the cloud of war came over here during
the war.
Oh, so that's like the new outfit.
Heart spell magic.
I guess it's one of the things we're going to be pulling
today.
It's the art of war.
It's the fog of war, guys.
There was there is a war going on the fog came in at the
right moment.
It's unexplored territory
Guys, it's just unexplored territory guys.
You didn't explore it.
That's why there's a fog
Busy as ever, huh agitant If you hadn't picked up he would
have missed today's special boo boo the maze Whoa!
Thank God it was a chair to help you.
It's really fun.
Feel free to handle work while we're on the call, Agent.
I'll be right here.
I don't really want to hang out yet.
She's so helpful.
When you're less busy, promise you'll call me again, okay?
I dehydrate a lot right now.
Unrelated to the game.
Oh!
She's a new outfit for the cat girl.
Hear my prayer.
Badger's
hidden treasure.
Anything sharp can be put to the side.
That way...
Why are these Scandinavian roots?
What if she's Scandinavian?
Lots of diversity.
Wifers from all regions.
Oh, she's so cute, though.
That's cute.
He's like, even there's a war going on, that's not going to
stop me from going, yeah?
Oh, there's the reindeer.
You know, who helped me wrap presents, guys.
She helped me wrap some presents.
We don't need to wait for a special occasion for that.
Like right now, I want to give my warmth to you, darling.
Don't I simply dazzle in this merry outfit?
Keep your eyes on me a little longer Oh, I like that gun
That's actually a really nice Gun design That's really cute
Oh, it's like They have like unique particles too For each
kid, I like that It makes it more special It's like Merry
Christmas Bitches What a battle To be with you every day And
night All my Happiness and joy.
Oh, it's like a...
It belongs to you.
I was...
Oh.
Morning.
Hey.
Everyone is working to you.
Give them a role model.
New logistic squads?
Maba!
Oh, they're like the behind the scenes people.
To help out.
Oh my god, we have a chef now!
Oh!
We have food!
We have- we can have a chef at the kitchen!
What's this?
Oh, wintertime relay.
New server-wide boss fight.
Ooh!
I'd actually like to try that.
Looks so fun.
Chat, what's the meta?
I- Whatever your heart's desire.
You just gotta find your waifu.
And that's the meta.
Frosty must die.
What is going on?
Gotta do some puzzles with your waifu.
The raid mode now permanent.
Oh, okay, so there's permanent raid mode now.
Oh, it's the in-game sound effects really loud.
I think there's like, there's a labyrinth in there.
I assume that's like the roguelike feature.
There seems to be a lot of gameplay modes, too.
Pima against powerful enemies, hero games.
Like, the game modes have not ended yet.
There seems to be a lot of game modes that you can do.
Or just a little bit.
I'll turn it down a little.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What does that say?
I had to look down to turn...
What did that say just now?
other new car uh oh she gets a room now guys it's okay she
has her own room now she was homeless before
whoa she could have fell and got a concussion guys i saved
her life look at that you're welcome girl
Sisyphus?
Aren't you supposed to be pushing a boulder?
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Thighs.
Save lives.
Oh, and there's a new map.
She's pushing two boulders right now, Doki.
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
Yeah, she is.
She's pushing two builders right now as we speak yeah whoa
so that is like i believe that is all the new update that's
coming in that i believe just launched came out too i know
some of the stuff that came out like yesterday as well um we
have also one more video i got i got spoiled a little bit um
i got spoiled uh what color the builders they were blue
that's right i pay attention
But, um, I, I, I got a little spoiled because I was trying
to, like, test this video out to make sure it works.
And, um, I was just like, oh my gosh.
Okay, let's just play the video.
I'll make a cup for the adjutant, too.
Stir it up there.
The cloud!
The fog of war!
Oh man.
Don't you hate it when the fog of war starts covering up my
waifu?
I really like this.
What do you like about this game, Tepo?
Oh my god, she fell!
Don't worry!
Don't worry, I've got you, girl!
Oh my god, okay, I guess...
All right, I guess I guess the foot would I was gonna help
you up with your hand.
I oh
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I gotta turn this down a little I Oh
man, that must have been a really hard fall don't worry.
I got you.
Oh Whoa
Okay, I turned it back up.
Okay.
Um.
You want me to try it myself?
So hot.
What?
What a kid.
It's not.
Guys, guys.
If you want to see more.
If you.
Damn.
Hmm.
If you want to see more, feel free to click the link pinned
in my chat or click the panel or do exclamation point
snowbreak or even scan the QR code because there's a lot of
free stuff you can get right now.
Yeah, if you want to see past the fog of war, feel free.
free to click on the link pinned in the chat right look okay
so when I got spoiled a little bit with the video I um I oh
my gosh I'm gonna look this way I I saw you know the
beginning part I was like whoa wow and I was like oh man
it's okay that's it should be the word that should be like
the extent it goes i was not expecting the path it would
take me from there i i really
i i really was not expecting that um i sound a little sick
don't worry my nurse is here to take care of me but who's
talking i probably need to watch a bit hey guys i'm new
who's your favorite Wifu Oh, too many attempts to send I
wanna ask Who the face is the
Okay, guys, this is worth it I wanna know Tell me who your
favorite Wait, I should add an emote here too I should be
like I don't I wasted No!
I thought it
would be next to my name.
I fumbled it.
I'll never know who their favorite wifus are.
Okay, so Kim.
They surely, surely they won't ignore me, right?
All right, there you go.
Maybe they'll be my, I add all in chat and be like, Guys,
who's your favorite wifu, everyone?
I should turn back the game.
I forgot I muted the game.
Oh, gosh.
Anyway, there are some important things I do need to tell
you guys about Snowbreak.
I got a little distracted there.
But, Snowbreak has, for those who are veterans in Snowbreak,
here are some new important updates for you guys.
But Snowbreak has made dual character releases a standard.
So, every version, big or small, will feature two new
characters.
So basically, there's going to be a lot of good updates with
the two new characters, big or small.
Most importantly, the second every character, the second
character in every version, it will be completely free to
obtain.
So every update, there'll be two characters, and then the
second character will be free.
So including your exclusive weapons and manifestation,
making the game extremely free to play friendly.
So if you're new here, and it'll be zero cost for a
five-star character.
So if you're a new player, you can jump right in, grab a
free SSR character, and also 110 free pulls.
So it's very free-to-play friendly for those people.
Especially if every update they give you like a five-star
free-to-play character.
I know, guys, guys, focus up.
Guys, look at me.
Look at me.
Guys, I need you to listen to this.
This is very important.
Look, okay, I have to put this up.
Guys, remember, guys, this game comes...
with free to play characters guys jingo okay look jingo
jingo jingo all you want to see you want to get past the fog
of war remember this information it is freedom it can be
free to play and it's very free to play friendly um and
players can claim the free moxer loris from january 1st
started yesterday you claim a free character right now you
saw the cat girl that was her you know I'll bring her in as
well let me see if I remember how to put her on I think it
was guys okay wait how do I do it again it was this right
alright uh where is she hello kitty kitty I think it was
whoa Wait, I actually want this.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Wait, this sound...
JK, go back to her.
We were so used to her already.
Oh, my.
I just realized I don't think I have her yet, but that means
I could pull her now.
Alright, so there are new outfits that we can pull right
now, so we shall go to the quartermaster right now.
Which, I, oh gosh.
Focus, Doki.
Oh, there we go.
So, perfect prayer.
The newest none outfit style and you can get a free moxer
simply by joining the memory mosaic event so she can
technically she can be oh gosh oh gosh sorry sorry my my
cross my cursor is going every right now the character
itself is free that can be obtained via um sorry i'm focused
though he like
That is her newest outfit.
And you can actually obtain the character for free by
joining a mosaic event right now.
Because it comes...
It...
It comes...
It came out yesterday.
I'm doing it, guys.
I'm doing it.
Anyway, let's...
it came out yesterday we're losing here all right let's
let's do the pull surely i'll get into the first try oh wait
i could just buy it yeah oh my god what great luck i have
guys i pulled it instantly isn't that crazy oh my okay oh
that's insane i i can't believe i pulled what streamer luck
did it guys i pulled her instantly isn't that insane wow
it's just that easy
it's just whoa okay sorry let's okay um maybe we could grab
her too let's This.
Okay, we got this.
There's...
We can focus up.
Also, the other new outfits.
What color were her eyes?
That's easy.
They were...
Yellow.
See?
I was right.
I didn't cheat whatsoever.
Oh, yeah.
What color were her eyes?
Huh?
What color?
Okay, you know what?
You know, I'll test you guys.
guys what color were her eyes huh all right what color what
color was babu's eyes is it yeah boobu's eyes what color
were boobu's eyes huh test you guys out she had eyes but yes
other new outfits are boobu's peculiar soul the magical girl
and i believe fennie the jingle of joy outfit so all of them
are available right now they end on january 29th so just
remember to grab their outfits before it's gone forever okay
guys just remember and you can participate you know we can
get it right now we want it to oh it's a puzzle so oh that's
easy i'm really good with puzzle explore the memory mosaic
where memory is shared with a girl are recorded.
Progress through the mosaic to earn rewards such as fully
modified signature weapon, signature logistics squad, and
exclusive drive items.
Send a certain amount of presence in any gameplay to obtain
one which can be consumed to draw any unused.
Okay, so...
Oh, I have no puzzle pieces.
Oh.
JK, I have to find the puzzle pieces.
Wait.
Wait, I'm inviting her!
Yay!
I pressed invite.
I had to press invite.
I was worried that it was gonna show...
Yeah!
We did it!
We got it!
Oh!
I can just draw everything.
Draw it too.
Oh.
I don't have anything yet.
So yeah, all I have to do You click here, press invite, and
then you get her.
It's just that easy, guys.
Look at that.
It's so simple.
Now I should have her, right?
I should have her.
Give me a check sec.
I need to double check.
Okay.
Why do I check my...
Oh, here.
Yay!
Wait, what's going on?
Why is my PC...
Okay.
Okay, sorry, I, well, okay, um, let's, I, I just want to
see, yeah, I got her, see, you can get a free character
right now, look at that, like, how do I change your clothes,
though, oh, there it is, here, I just bought this, I want to
change that right now, oh, my God, okay,
Please, please calm down.
I still have, I still have like an hour and 40 minutes.
I need a power through.
Calm down.
Oh, I need to lower the BGM a little bit more.
Wait, were you guys able to hear me?
I mean, I don't even know if you guys are even paying
attention to me right now.
But I just want to be sure that the BGM is not drowning me
out.
I honestly I have doubts if you guys are paying attention to
my voice right now
anyway there is a thing called waifu interaction
appreciation so there is a thing we could do with bubu so so
let us go talk to boo boo real quick we'll go over here real
quick first assume like ah boo boo where's boo boo boo pure
heart where is she redacted i like that oh no no no no
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to focus right now, but I'm doing the
best I could.
I'm being lost in the sauce right now.
Boo-boo, where are you?
Boo-boo.
Is that you, Boo-boo?
Oh, Boo-boo, there you are!
There you are, Boo-boo!
Okay.
so for booboo when you equip this you can actually call her
right now and be like hey girl you up
I could call her right now and it's a way for them to
present the story and bring more engaging story-driven
conversations with these girls and but it's very limited
focus di and and is only available from december 18 to
january 29th so make sure to download the game and check it
out before it's too late or she won't answer your calls
anymore all right so let me call her real quick oh i need to
change it first all right hello i'm I'm calling her.
Can you pick my call?
Pizzy as ever, huh, Adjutant?
As me.
If you hadn't picked up, you would have missed today's
special.
Fubu the Mage.
Oh my god, wait, I think I saw this video.
Wait, I think we saw this video.
I think I know where this is heading.
I knew you didn't want to hang up.
Were you hoping I'd tell you something fun, agitant?
Yeah?
Let's see.
Hmm.
Oh, I've got it.
You know this, agitant.
I taught myself divination and talents in drawing books.
Oh, you're so smart, boo-boo.
I am looking at the beautiful.
roses surrounding her they're just as beautiful as here
she's so smart guys agitant if you could pick one which
class sounds more fun flying yeah I would say prophet I
should have said prophecy I could predict the future
So many kinds of magic, all totally different.
Maybe I should master just one first.
Dark, light, elemental.
Which one do you think suits me best, Adjutant?
Um.
Elemental, because then you can master all the elements.
Wait, you guys can see my cat.
But I'm head patting her, guys.
Look at that.
I'm patting her on the head.
potatoes, chestnuts, maybe even schwo to clap red.
Listen to me.
Do I sound way too obsessed with food?
I'm pet patting her.
Look, I'm rubbing her shoulders.
Good job for being so smart, boo-boo.
I'll be right here.
Oh?
Your personal companion is...
I'm sorry.
Reading is really hard right now.
I don't know why.
So, companion is here to spend some delightful idle time
with you.
Adjust the settings to customize the experience and make
even sweeter.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Don't forget to move the camera to get closer to the girl.
So many girls really have to shout their lines when they
transform.
You can enable the timer and the camera.
You can enable a timer in settings and the game will exit
autumn.
Yo, you gotta time yourself, bro.
You might be trapped in here forever.
You might want to think twice before trying it.
You can change or stop the- Yeah, this is very- this is a
very dangerous game mode.
You gotta put the timer in there.
It's not every day.
I find a nice quiet spot.
Oh, there's- Oh my god, it's like- it's like those like um
you know you have to play in the background while you're
working you know yeah customize exclusive audio experience
for your idle chat open reminder you set the time to give
you warm voice oh she can motivate you click the chat and go
in to share conversation with you topics depend on each
choice you make Drawing the chat, so your choices can lock
new voicemails for even trigger special surprise special
events.
Alright, cool.
I understand now.
So...
Oh.
Wait, how do I...
I can't do anything.
Oh, I can take a picture of her.
Yay!
I can share her on Twitter.
Wait, I want to...
Give me that.
It's not every day.
I find a nice, quiet spot like that.
Give me a second.
Do it.
All right.
Give me a second.
I gotta do something real quick, guys.
All right.
How do I...
Okay, there you go.
Give me a second.
I gotta tweet something real quick, guys.
It'll be really fast.
Wait, where did I save it?
What did I do?
Oh my god, where's the photo?
Wait, where did I save the photo of my new waifu?
Wait, I got it.
Sorry, I can't take another picture.
Oh my god, I can't.
I'm only given one photo.
Oh wait, I can't.
All right.
Where is it?
Okay, I found it.
All right.
It's okay, guys.
Give me a sec, guys.
This is very important.
all right let's go okay sorry what did she tell me to do
should i come up with a few catchphrases oh okay so i can
set a timer here and then i assume oh these are all the time
oh these are like reminders it's not every day i find a nice
quiet spot like this okay so what i sorry i need to remind
myself uh remind myself what the instructions she gave me oh
i need to talk to her hello hello sorry i had to like you
know like when you're you're like with someone really
beautiful and you want to like just talk about her all the
time you know i need to start a timer when you guys are
right give me a sec i might need to start a timer guys I...
All right, can you...
Wait, oh, I can't set a time.
Yeah, and then you want to like, you know, put your bragging
about her to the world, you know?
Do you understand, guys?
You're like, guys!
Look how beautiful she is.
All right.
Elemental magic is the umbrella term for four basic types.
Water, fire, fire...
I can't believe she's with me, guys.
Usually, if you can master even two...
You're already considered a pretty great mage so agitant if
it were you, which element would you start with?
Water if you learn water magic you could use it to water
flowers or even do the laundry Because I'm very thirsty
right now I've got it if you practiced in something cooler
maybe what no shirt then you wouldn't have to worry about
soaking that is so true that is so smart but i think you
just wear like a swimsuit you know
oh hello uh fortune telling so tarot cards aren't for
brimming they're actually for fortune telling i totally you
burn them like talismans after all these books I think I'm
getting the hang of it agitant let me do a quick reading for
you she's so smart oh she's gonna read for me how's she
gonna read oh I was supposed to click something else after
uh uh Moon God.
This one signals opportunity.
A really good one.
I don't know exactly what you're working on, but just grab
it.
And your odds of success should weigh out.
Oh my God, 2026 is my year.
She thinks it's my year.
Just the way you hope.
Yeah.
Wait, does that mean like, was there anything that missed
something when when I said the other, when I asked this?
If it were you, which element would you...
Oh my god, the voice is...
If you practiced in something cool, I really am a
natural-born genius at this.
Was there anything I missed when she was doing that?
Feels like the...
Whoa!
For two to just lie here together.
Oh, you want me to call someone over?
Is that what you mean?
The hang of elemental magic.
Maybe it can even shave a bit off the utility bill.
I've heard some people fly on magic carpets.
Maybe my bed sheet could work too.
You might want to think twice before trying any new quirky
type gizmos.
What?
Is there nothing bonus?
Oh, the chair?
Oh.
Rooms used to be the classic way to fly.
But they're not exactly safe, and honestly, they're pretty
rough on the buns, so people have moved on from them.
These days, flying tools fall into three schools of thought.
The everyday type, the tech type, and the quirky type.
Every day uses stuff from daily life.
Blankets, cloaks, ordinary things turned into flying gear.
Tech gives normal vehicles a magical upgrade.
Oh my god, I spilled water.
Oh.
Guys, I don't know why I'm fumbling so much right now.
Oh my god.
I'm just trying to listen to...
I'm just trying to listen to my waifu.
Because I should have learned water that she was so red.
I should have taken off my shirt.
You actually prefer the quirky type?
Then maybe I should try growing a tail too Hmm Which suits
me better A cute little cat tail Or a curly piggy one
Why I think cat tail Yeah cat tail for sure I agree
I know right If only we can find a second person to lie in
bed with her If only wait what's this agitant what are you
ready i'm going to take the blindfold off now what is this
wait what
what is this welcome to the haven of your little magic girl
boo boo now that you're here i'm not letting you slip away
so easily what Hello?
Oh my god!
She was very thirsty, guys.
I got her some water, guys.
She was very thirsty.
Let me drink in your magic.
As much as you'll allow.
Oh, you want my water, too?
Here.
Only then can I truly become a powerful magic girl.
Yeah, I got some here.
If you want some water.
Wait, what?
Oh, yeah, my water in my pocket, right?
Oh, you're right.
How did you know I have a juice box in my pocket?
But before that, we need a little bit of preparation.
Oh, you need a straw with my juice box?
Don't worry, I got you.
First, we'll brew a potion.
This is not how I remember.
Man, this is...
Man, this is Wendy's.
Let's see what the grimoire says.
This is me, like...
I'm trying so hard to focus right now.
What does the Grim War say?
Oh, Blavu.
Thank you for the raid.
Guys, do not judge Blavu.
Do not judge me, right?
Welcome, everyone.
Don't break a David's own stream.
If you guys want to check out...
I'm just...
reading a book with my wife right now I'm just it's nothing
weird we're reading a book no we're reading a book together
we're reading the grimoire
pour in some tree of life she's making me a potion a very
magical girl potion slowly do you guys want to check out
this game feel free to click The link been in the chat.
Where did she get unicorn tears?
How do I...
Please, I understand.
I don't know what to do.
Oh, my God.
Nothing boo-boo can't handle.
Okay.
Whoa!
She's making me water, guys.
See?
She's...
She's making me water.
Look at that.
Wow.
It's my water.
Agitant?
I'm not strong enough to channel it alone.
I'll need your help to absorb it.
Oh, yeah?
I have a towel.
Does that work?
Here's how it works.
You'll drink the potion and let the magic flow through you
until I can draw the resonance out and join it with mine.
Oh, that seems pretty easy.
So how are you gonna draw?
Am I, how am she gonna draw the resonance out?
Obviously, I'm gonna, like, it's gonna come out in the upper
part of the body.
Yeah, with a straw, right?
With a straw.
That's what the straw is for, right?
Yeah, through a straw.
You're okay with that?
Then, may I feed you the potion?
Why does she need to feed me if it's through a straw?
It's bitter.
Let me taste.
Oh, here.
Yeah, yeah, here.
Here's the bottle.
Oh, man.
over to here.
We should add a little sweetness.
The camera shook because she shook the bottle really hard.
Honey, caramel, or maybe a little sweetness from me.
Which would you like?
I think Kira Nova would be pretty good.
You don't even have to say.
Oh, you got caramel syrup?
Wow, you think of everything.
Yeah, she brought me caramel syrup Guys, she...
A drop here, a little across my collarbone.
Oh, why did you spill it on your collarbone?
Here.
Oh man, now, oh bro, that's the hygienic booboo.
Done.
I had to tint all yours.
You ruined it.
It's gonna be so hard to clean up Caramel.
That is like this.
So warm.
You got me warm carabelle too?
It's coming.
Oh my god.
I can feel the magic building up inside me.
I'm so thirsty for it.
It's almost unbearable.
I should put a timer on.
What should I do?
Oh no!
We gotta call the ambulance!
What do we do?
Oh whoa!
Let me help you speedily.
along the channeling process.
Oh my God.
Sound guy, is the volume okay, Sam, do you want me to lower
it a little bit more, Sound guy, or is this like the perfect
volume right now?
Like maybe we should lower it a little bit more, don't you
think so, Sound guy?
Don't, don't break.
Oh, Sound guy, you want me to lower the volume a little bit?
Oh yeah, no, sorry guys.
I might have to, I might have to lower it
Don't put this on me.
Oh my god, look at what.
Look at what.
This spot right here.
Wait, wait.
Oh, don't we want to put the straw.
Guys, we're going to put the straw.
The straw on hand tongue.
Oh my god, you don't see me doing this, but I'm like
touching my forehead right now.
I'm fucking sweating right now
I don't know why it's so hot in my room I don't want any of
it to go to waste I need them
Oh my god
Man, you're so bad with the straw!
Your magic tastes incredible.
Oh my god.
Oh my
god.
They're so warm.
I'm glad I'm on Twitch right now.
I think something inside me is changing.
Oh my god.
I'm on Twitch right now.
From now on, should I be calling you...
Master?
After all, our contract is finally complete.
So, Master, don't forget to keep sharing your magic with me,
okay?
This is... guys...
Yeah, it's not my fault.
I should have put a timer on.
Oh, what would you like to remind me of?
I should.
What does she say if I said that in four seconds?
All right.
You might want to think twice before trying any new quirky
type gizmos.
does every four seconds is she gonna remind me again what
exercise remind me to exercise does she do it oh oh as in
like four oh 12 oh four okay wait what time okay it is i've
been here for 20 23 minutes oh my gosh Okay, 30, 40, 50, 60,
70, and 18.
Okay, it's 18.
Um.
Oh.
Five.
All right.
Does she do it?
It's almost time.
You really have to shuffle the lines when they transform.
Kind of embarrassing.
Okay, it's almost happy new year.
It's like watching the ball drop.
Come on, we're almost there.
Hold?
She's gonna send us a little reminder.
Happy New Year.
Yeah.
Hold?
Come on.
It's not 605 yet.
So many words in this book.
Oh, look at that.
Give me a little pet up.
She didn't remind me.
How did I mess it up?
What did I do wrong?
Why don't we get my little reminders?
Huh?
The
reminders?
No, that's not the time.
That's how long I've been here.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh, apparently there's other interactions too?
Wait, what other interactions can we get?
How do we leave?
If you're this bad, so...
I don't really want to hang up yet.
When you're less busy, promise you'll call me again.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
I'll call you again.
Yeah, time passes so fast when you're in a...
When you're in a Discord call with your girl.
Oh my gosh.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go check out our squad real quick.
Um, and I gotta find the cat.
That meow?
Oh, here you go.
Does she have an interaction?
Wait, no, that's not her.
You're not the right meow.
Oh, there you go.
That's my meow.
Okay.
So...
Oh, she doesn't have one yet.
Wait, who has one?
Oh, it's only her right now, right?
Because anyone...
Who else has...
Who else has interaction, or is it only Boo-boo right now,
chat?
Does anyone know?
the five stars i wouldn't know well it's time to download
the game to find out guys
guys it's time to download the game what's this oh
guys click on the link pinned in the pin in the chat or the
panel or or the oh my god guys oh my god i can't leave oh my
god i can't leave oh
oh i oh i thought i could leave whenever oh no oh it was her
oh oh oh i'm oh
breakfast time Wait, I know this scene?
Why?
Oh, no.
Wait, what do you?
Skip.
I got worried.
I saw someone with I know this scene in all exclamation
point and then snuff zoom.
And then I got scared.
I was like, what do you mean you know this scene?
Guys, no, I guess the reason why.
I had to stop it Was because it's giveaway time
Why are we punished For this one guy Look guys, guys, guys
Hear me out, hear me out It's not because of this one guy
It's because Um
it's it's because guys we have to do a giveaway right now
for five 25 steve gift cards how is that free stuff yay guys
oh my god everyone guys guys remember we have a giveaway
right now
this how about this i'll put it as that so it's almost like
we're there we're almost like it's almost like we're still
there guys so to enter huge shout out again to snowbreak for
sponsoring this stream and uh for um her giving us um we're
giving us a 25 steam gift cards uh for jesus christ for
for the Gomez, thank you for the 25 gifted subs for shit,
where was I?
For sponsoring this stream and for giving us $25 steam gift
cards to God damn, to to why is it always that part when she
does that?
To give away to the dragons.
So, make sure to click the link pinned in the chat, the
description, sorry, I'm not on YouTube.
The panel, we're scanning QR code or do exclamation point,
or do exclamation point snow brick and
so let me let me do host do the giveaway right now okay to
enter just
to enter just do exclamation point enter if you want me to
release, release, release the cheeks.
You guys gotta remember to enter, oh my god, it's so fast.
If you want to release the cheeks, just remember to do
exclamation point, enter to enter the giveaway, release the
Kraken.
Yes, that's better.
Release the Kraken, we will need you to enter the giveaway.
And um, and then and then make sure your twitch or twitter
dms are open as a staff member will be sending you a dm for
the code they will not be sending you guys any links so
please don't click on any suspicious links okay guys uh but
they will they will be oh gosh they will be why is it so
hard to talk right now so just just don't click on any
suspicious links but make sure your twitch dms or your
twitter dms are open because they will send you the steam
gift card if you win the giveaway hashtag sponsored by
snowbreak all right hey guys i'll give you guys 10 more
seconds to enter the way exclamation point enter and if you
guys want if you want us to release the Kraken make sure to
scan the QR code and download the game all right I'll give a
countdown for that if you want to enter last minute 10 9 8 7
6 5 4 3 2 1
Otaku, congratulations on being the first winner.
Make sure to have your Twitch DMs or your Twitter DMs open,
and a staff member will be sending you a $25 gift card.
Yay!
All right, now that one, since one winner was announced,
we'll show you one cheek.
Every winner, I move it slowly and slowly further away.
Wait, that's a little bit too.
I give you guys too much for that.
Let me...
Alright.
So...
Second winner.
You can still enter if you want to, by the way.
You can still exclamation point enter if you want.
Sniper Lobster!
Congratulations!
I'm being the second winner!
Here you go.
I moved it a little bit more.
Congratulations!
For being the second...
Three more to go, guys.
Three more winners to announce.
Sean, 1611.
Make sure you're Twitch and Twitter DMs are open so they can
send you the giveaway.
Look at that.
Another one.
And another one.
And how many do I have?
I lost count, guys.
count two more two more okay legend dragon congratulations
on winning a steam gift guide all right one last dragon and
then the Kraken will be freed one last one last winner all
right I'll let people continue to enter if you guys want to
my Five, four, three, two, one.
I saw LeVon Doom.
Congratulations on being the final winner and the Kraken has
been released.
Congratulations.
Yay.
Congratulations to all the winners.
winners again huge shout out to snow break containment zone
for the sponsor i really i really do appreciate it oh my
gosh okay anyway back to add okay ad break within the ad
break is over so now now we're gonna go to the base gameplay
part all right And you remember how to go to the base, guys.
Oh, here you go.
The base time.
So we get a little house.
And...
Oh, hey.
Hello, everyone.
It's still summer!
Yay!
Oh, my God.
I'm such a good person.
Look at all these rooms I've given the girls.
Look at that.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so strong.
Oh, no.
Oh, whoa, she dropped her contact lenses.
She's so stressed out.
I am a very good CEO.
Look at that.
And I make sure everyone is relaxed and having a good time
and not stressed out.
And, um, oh, look at that.
Oh, my God, we're having a party, too.
See?
Unwind tension.
Snowbreak containment zone.
Oh, hey, look.
Oh my god, there's a bar too.
Hello, everyone.
Hey, girls.
Go ahead and sit down.
Oh, I can drink coffee with my girls.
So this is the...
So you can go to the base and interact with the girls.
Aro.
Okay.
Invite girl to room.
Oh, is there a room?
Bro, you need...
Bro, girl.
Why did you tell me you want me to decorate your room?
Alright, change furniture.
Don't worry.
Oh, that's all she wants.
She's, like, very minimalistic.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, wait.
I can still... Wait, what's this?
Oh,
okay.
There we go.
What's going on?
What is she doing?
He died.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I gotta leave this room.
Okay.
We gotta find...
Apparently the new edition is Mia's room.
So...
Oh, it's summon.
So we gotta find Mia.
Where does Mia live?
go back don't go back it was getting good if you guys want
to see interactions with whose room was that you want to see
more interactions with hiru make sure to download the link
the game right now pin in the chat or even like you know in
the panel or the qr code okay there's cyrus's room benny's
room there's mia
Oh, I can see it.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Oh, there she is.
This is a new one.
Hello, Mia.
So apparently this...
Oh, my God.
I'm gone.
It's like I was never here.
Oh, my God.
It's like first person.
Okay, I was going to say, how can I move?
Um...
Okay.
Alright, so...
What?
Okay.
I think I feel a little better.
All done!
Squeaky clean and smelling amazing.
Okay, okay, okay, that's...
Alright.
That's good, okay.
Hi, Mia!
I had your tent.
Okay.
Alright, at least we know.
What's this?
Switch actions.
Oh, I can make her...
I can do it.
Oh!
That's so stupid!
Okay, say please, please leave the shower.
We have complaints that you are, you are increasing the
water bill, so I need you to leave the shower.
What's the story?
Okay, no, I don't have, apparently, we don't have a lot of
affinity points.
Apparently, I just sit down.
That's me.
Is there anything I could do in the room?
I keep accidentally pressing E because E is like the
interaction button for me.
That's it, right?
Is there anything else we could do in her room?
Any...
Oh!
Oh, the furniture?
Well, she has no furniture.
How do I give her furniture?
Oh, I got a decorator room.
How do I decorate a room?
Oh, I have to buy her furniture.
Oh, my God.
All right.
We're going to buy her furniture.
I guess from this, right?
GG selections.
Where's Mia?
This is Mia, right?
Oh.
I have enough.
I'll grab her this.
And this.
Don't worry.
I'll make your own beautiful Mia.
I'll make you love me.
It's like you've never been a jerk.
I'm just so really bad.
I'm just very oblivious.
I was like, what do you want?
You want water, right?
Yeah.
It's just...
Oh, I thought I just bought...
Sure.
Please stop.
Why do you always shower every time I come here?
Please.
Our water bill.
Our water bill is too high.
Is this?
Mia the water bill.
Bill, please.
Hey, look at this cute photo I took, girl.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I give her the...
Oh, her hair is like cat ears.
Wait, is she an act?
No, she's not a cat.
It's just...
She just jelled it like that.
Oh, that's cute.
Like, we have...
Yeah, we have like 10 women in here, guys.
It's not very good.
We have to keep...
We have a pool.
We have a hot tub.
We are not very good with our water.
uh rashing our water whoa see she could have died guys i
saved her life i literally saved her life chat she could
have hit her head on the floor and then got a concussion i'm
a fucking hero we saved it exactly look at that i did that
that looped right okay oh so it's oh so i do this we just
interact oh what fun are we having today oh there's stuff oh
it's this oh that's the two person one oh it's really cute i
wonder if there's other interactions oh there's a kitchen
for topia oh that's cute oh my god look it went up by seven
all right that's not here she can have Food and a photo
stand We got locked the shower room
Alright, that's nice That's cute So you need to have like
Find your favorite way of food You can just have Like this
Oh It feels nice and sound Oh, that's cute The room is Oh,
it's a doggy rug Oh my god.
Okay, I actually want her rug.
That's actually a cute-ass rug.
That is so cute.
But I think, Mia, get out.
I want this room.
This is my room now, Mia.
I want to go out together.
Wait, I actually want this room, Mia.
Get out.
I claim this room.
We'll just, we'll give you a room with a shower.
That's all you need.
Oh, I have the affinity level now.
Okay, well, I can get it to level 10.
I'm going to skip to the second one.
Because the first one is just like, she's just like, oh,
just like introducing us.
So I'm just going to, right here.
There's not enough room for two people in this room, guys.
Like, I need my personal space.
the other stuff.
Oh!
I can swap sets.
I didn't realize that.
Oh, I keep going back.
I guess we're missing the... Oh, we don't have the blue yet.
So, uh...
I think the fluffy wall is the cutest.
Yeah, we'll put this here.
Stars and clouds and even the moon, they feel all... Oh!
That's cute.
All right.
What's your story like?
Yay, free stuff.
I think, I think, like, only at the end does it.
I think we're just, she's still, we're still just friends.
That is cheap.
Yay, free stuff.
Guys, she gives me free things.
oh there's other interactive interactivity here let's see
there's the hot spring retreat where's that is this oh my
god bro what the fuck is our water bill
there we go also apparently um only two had their twitch dms
or twitter dms open so please make sure to have your twitch
or twitter dms open guys if you guys won the uh giveaway
guys our mods the mods can't dm you got the moment three
people have not opened their twitch or slash twitter dms to
receive their gift card pick other winners then oh it's only
twitch dms or sorry only twitch dms guys jesus okay i know
like pools and hot tubs are a bit hard to maintain because
bodily fluids are disgusting like you know having the sweat
On the...
Are your eyes getting dizzy from all this?
The sweat and oil.
You have to clean it.
Does it meet your expectations?
No need to rush with your answers.
Yeah, just shower before entering.
Why not let us indulge you with a bath?
Whoa.
And then you can tell us how you feel later.
Whoa?
Guys, I'm not a child.
I can wash myself.
splash roulette.
Wait, there's gameplay here?
Hello.
Oh, there, all right.
What's this splash roulette?
How do I play?
Infuse your deep affection into a splash shot.
Pull a trigger and aim into the one you adore.
After completing Switch between let and select your favorite
girl for practice.
I'm not here to practice.
I'm here to play.
Oh, I shoot myself.
Winning is all about using items.
Marley oh my god wait wait I know what this game is
oh my god wait I know what this game is please don't go easy
on me all right okay so the shooting button what's your
target okay so I had to shoot between you but I
I didn't I won guys I'm winning the roulette we did set a
safe word didn't we
oh herself wait oh did she did it oh that nothing what a let
down what a let down wait what she wanted she gets a an
extra turn?
Oh, if it has nothing.
Yep.
Oh my gosh, she's wild.
She gets another empty round?
What's the letdown?
Oh my god.
How lucky is she?
My turn now.
Oh no.
Oh.
that's right my turn I like my icon that's right hatchet hit
the boom headshot that's right she was too wild all
right I made it a second part okay all right
oh yeah yeah reveals whether next bullet be a splash shot oh
okay yeah that's good make your opponent will be able to do
anything on their next turn the hand because okay how do I
want to use my items alright use
oh that means it's on me yeah next shot it will be a
fireworks or yeah there you go I'll get another shot
okay alright alright Okay.
Oh, this is...
I'm a shooter.
I'll risk it.
Yes!
I knew it!
I took the gamba!
I'm gaming!
That should come in handy.
There you go.
She restored her health?
That's cheating!
Oh my god.
She's actually cheating.
How dare she use items?
I am the agitant.
Bullshit.
You need any of this game?
Don't worry.
It's Snowbreak Containment Zone.
I'm going to click on the link pinned in my chat or in the
panel or exclamation point snowbreak.
We can still win.
Don't give up.
She has so many turns.
Okay.
Okay, we got more items.
Let's give this a try.
You.
How dare you?
Are you serious?
Now, isn't it?
She locked me up.
Oh, nice.
That's right.
I'm a streamer.
I always have.
But she locked me up.
Isn't it?
No!
I forgot she locked me up.
Your face is rather flushed.
Agitant.
She got me.
Okay.
It's my turn.
How many do I get?
I got.
That bullets the path for your next shot.
Okay, I got a health gem.
Oh, this is risky.
Um.
Okay.
I'm gonna lock her up.
And then shoot her twice.
There's no way.
And then...
I could technically shoot her twice.
Yes!
No, I don't need a heal yet.
She doesn't have anything.
She can't do anything.
Wait.
We did set a safe word.
Okay, and then I'll...
I'll eat one.
And I'll shoot her again.
Yes!
Oh my god, I just always shoot.
That's the key.
Just always shoot.
This should come in handy.
Oh my gosh, she's just continuously eating the...
Are you serious?
There's no way.
There's nothing in there.
I took both shots.
Stupid.
Learn how to count.
There's only two shots and I had both shots.
That's right.
I knew how to count.
I shoot myself and get an extra turn.
Alright.
Got an extra turn And I have extra items too Okay, it
doubles the power I got health Oh Well, I do have two double
shots So I'm going to use one And then This is the risk I'm
willing to take Yes!
Thrilling victory!
I did it!
We did it guys This isn't so bad.
See or shoot you win Never back down Look at that What is
challenge mode?
Like what do I get out of it?
Oh wait.
I can't challenge anyone.
Oh Unlock after defeating at least two.
Okay.
We don't want to wait.
I want to do one more shot.
I'll do her All
right Oh, shoot.
Can't you go a little easy on...
No dodging.
Never punished.
That's right.
How...
How does she do it?
I don't like it.
Can't you go a little easy on me?
Bam!
Got him.
All right, I have x-ray, too.
Oh, and I have handguns.
cuffs.
How many shots?
Okay, I have three.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna risk it.
It's three.
There's no way.
There's no way the first shot.
Nice!
Okay.
Oh my god.
I was like, there's no way the first shot is the fireworks.
Okay.
Alright, and then we use glasses.
Okay, it's fireworks.
So I Alright, and then I shoot myself here Oh my god I'm
strategizing, I'm strategizing right now And then And then
Watch this I lock her up That's right And then bam There we
go There we go I'm min-maxing right now.
And then there's one more.
And then.
Bam!
Another turn.
My turn never ends.
My turn.
That's right.
Is this the whole game?
We're still on the side game content.
Okay, one out of one.
Oh, that's easy.
All right, we look.
That works.
That's right.
You're never gonna shoot.
I have a hundred percent accurate.
Still my turn.
All right.
And then.
Bam.
Aren't you getting hit shot.
It's never.
It's not gonna be her turn ever.
Easy on me.
Okay.
Now it's her turn.
play like for 20 years.
Ooh, sweet luck.
Oh, no.
Wait, that's not fair.
Ooh, sweet luck.
Okay, wait, that's not fair.
Okay, wait.
Oh, no.
Okay, please, please don't get the gamma.
Please don't get the gamma.
Don't get the gamma.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
There's only one shot left.
It was literally eight.
Alright.
And then, bam!
Aren't you gonna fire?
My shoes are wet Never punished That's right Bam I win
That's right Never challenge me I am always a winner
Thrilling victory That's fucking right That's right
Moodookey
It's right You dare challenge me The gamer Alright what
other What other places can we visit There's also a Beach It
says a beach here Or is it I assume Oh I assume it's this
right Escape to your private beach I own a private island
Okay frosty toss up Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
Guys, bro, how rich am I?
We're so fucking rich.
Come to my island, guys.
Hey,
you are agitant.
Get up, darling.
You'll roast if you lie there any longer.
Yeah, my own private island.
Oh, my God.
She's like, you got jealous.
Oh, wow.
Ladies, ladies, one at a time.
Ladies.
I'm in maxing right now.
I'm air of maxing.
Hi, agitants.
Oh, I can make her change outfits.
Nice.
Wait, can I make her change outfit too?
I thought you'd come find me.
Look, it's... Oh, my!
Need help.
You can come to me.
Okay.
She's so cold, okay?
Well, we got...
She... She's so cold, guys.
She is so cold.
You guys want to see, you can also download the game right
now on the, in the chat.
I keep trying to say the description of my mind is so,
what's this?
No, I don't, I don't trust you.
I don't, that, me looking at that shirt, I don't know where
the bikini is.
I, I don't trust, at least when I look here, I can see a bit
of the bikini.
I can see a, okay, no, that was the red flag.
I cannot see any, I don't know where it is.
I don't know where it is.
I don't trust you.
Oh, it's another mini-game.
You'll see girls' orders and perform actions to toss
ingredients into a cup they're holding.
Oh!
It's a cooking game.
Uh, at least one star to unlock.
You girls will take turns placing orders.
Every successful dessert earns you more points.
Okay.
You'll need to identify the right dessert recipe and choose.
the correct ingredients each dessert has three parts oh okay
i can do this this can't be hard me darling when have i
tried what else you guys have multiple times
all right what do you want this and definitely this how
about a prudy rainbow how do i make that A fruity,
rainbow...
Oh!
Fruity...
Orange...
Sprinkles!
Tangier...
Wait, that's...
Oh, there we go!
It has to be milk!
Oh!
Okay, I got it.
This is trial and error.
Relax, darling.
Take the shot.
That'll be a piece of dick.
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh, I have to...
Oh, I was like, where am I shooting?
I'm so good.
A perfect throw, darling.
Is it just me or did you just...
No!
Oh, it's the yellow!
Oh, don't...
Oh!
It's okay, you don't need ice cream on it.
Guys, I'm sorry, my eyes were not, my eyes weren't on the
left.
That's okay, she didn't need the ice cream.
Failure!
They were this close.
It wasn't me, okay?
This one doesn't count.
One more game.
Okay, okay, we got this one.
Okay, broody.
Okay, I got this.
Honestly, understandable.
Technically, she still got it.
just say don't get distracted on me and she did distract me
so it is on here it's on here
all right this was a nightmare on the phone oh my god there
we go we got it perfect that wasn't so hard all right here
we go unstoppable can't wait to taste our victory with you
Yeah We're so good at this Absolutely delicious Want to
taste darling?
A shared victory is the sweetest kind Yeah, I'm gaming this
one was I can't believe this one was harder than the other
game Oh, there's so many There's like a got gauntlet too
Yeah, she's Classes lady Her?
Well, guys, if you guys want to do her, make sure To
download the That's right That's right I'm gonna tease it
If you want to try To play with this character You gotta try
it yourself, guys There's so many other places we have to go
Alright, the healing Center.
Okay, we should save Healing Center at last.
Let's go to the cozy parlor first.
Yes, I have a feeling we should save the Healing Center for
last when we need healing.
Check, check, check.
Oh, hey.
Oh, it's like a jazz club.
You like jazz?
Whoa.
Oh my god, you get my own little dance.
Adjutant, a drink.
This color really fits the mood tonight, don't you think?
Whoa.
Have we shown off the normal games?
Like, not yet, we will get there, guys.
We will get there.
We will not.
Doki, how long have you been shooting?
We will get there.
Darling, why aren't you drinking?
They're not gonna make it, Togey.
You're, this is the gameplay.
The others are bonus.
Alright, there's apparently something you do at the bar.
The card interaction feature?
I'm un...
Oh, unless that's, like, back in the main base.
Or is it here?
Oh, is this a story?
Whoa!
Oh, it's the same thing.
Okay, I already saw this.
Where's the car?
Oh, here.
Is it this?
Oh, buff for blush.
Cheerio.
It must be this.
Classic mode.
We're all playing against.
I'm not.
All right.
Sure, let's do it.
Let's go.
What is this?
Okay.
The ice card.
Already feeling the move.
You'd better keep going.
Oh!
I think I know what game this is.
There's no way to think I'm lying.
Okay, complicated isn't really my style.
Okay.
I didn't see it.
One snow card.
All right, watch this.
Two snow card.
That's right.
Can I just make all the cards vanish?
Am I telling the truth?
Three snow cards!
Liar!
Wait, how do I call it a liar?
There's no way there's that many snow cards.
You can't be too careful, right?
There's no way.
Okay.
Oh, it's here.
Liar.
I like how you're trying to...
That's right.
I knew it.
I was like, oh my gosh, you gotta take a shot.
Yeah, I was like, are all of them snow cards?
Not bad.
Oh, every time, every time she's lying, she's got to take a
shot.
Another snow card.
I don't care.
All right.
Oh, it's her new.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Looks like I need to adjust my strategy.
Three snow cards?
There's no way.
Liar.
Oh, my gosh.
yet.
Oh, wait, yes, I knew it!
I knew it!
Wait, what?
Is that a snow?
Oh, my God.
Is that Joker card?
That's a Joker card.
Oh, my God.
Want to drink this yourself, or should I help you?
Guys, I purposely, I knew I knew she was telling the truth,
and I wanted to take the shot, guys.
I wanted to showcase you guys like what happens when you
mess up so it was calculated you should I did that on
purpose guys the house always wins
who thunders okay okay what
That's messed up.
Guys, it's all calculated.
Look what I conjured up.
I didn't think.
She didn't look like someone that would call me out.
That's why I put her on the other table.
You must have gone easy on me, honey.
I lost!
Okay, no, no, no.
This can't be.
We always win here.
Wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
We gotta swap the girls.
It's because those girls tried too hard.
Those girls tried way too hard.
Okay, same card.
Looks like it's time to get serious.
What should I do next?
All right.
Oh, right.
Okay, what?
I mean, that makes sense.
One card.
One flame.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's boo-boo.
Oh, you instantly do it up.
Do you not have a flame card, girl?
Oh, man.
Oh, she is a lightweight.
One shot?
Well, the shot has not been fully digested in your kidneys
yet, bro.
Oh, yeah, she's already out.
Wait, she's already out.
Wait, wait, she's actually already out Our liver, sorry,
liver, liver Kidney, it's the same, right?
Lightning card
Alright Cool lightnings That's right, you want to call me
out, don't you?
That's right, look at that, bam!
Take a shot!
Danger has a way of hiding where temptation is see i told
you guys i just needed to swap the girls out these girls
don't know how to play just that easy i'm not that easy to
beat
all right here we go would have thought playing cards with
my darling could get this and oh oh this isn't looking too
promising yeah this is part of the gameplay too all right oh
my god yeah i was gonna say why would you call it it's one
card look at that that's right
oh she's out she's out she took the one we're shot one and
done get out of here now it's 1v1 doki wins like doing
absolutely nothing
alright alright
one one nice card guys guys I don't think these girls know
how to play guys I I literally just I literally just like
rearranged the table and got that I was like who does it
guys whose is it whose first time is in the playlist game
guys to see me like this yeah
Winner winner Look at that We did it.
Alright, it's time.
It's time for the real game and by real game.
I mean it's time for the healing center
Oh, yeah, apparently Apparently audio guy actually was like
we have to lower the volume a little bit So we might yeah,
we gotta leave the base and then we'll come back and fix the
BGM Look, this was the audio guy did tell me to do this i
wasn't this i'm not live but it's just for the music because
apparently the music was a little too loud all right go back
to the base all right let's see and now we go to the healing
center
wait a minute audio guy wait why did you want to lower the
music
Wait, wait a minute, wait a minute, no, we gotta, we gotta
go back.
I just realized why he wanted to lower the music.
I just, no,
no, he's, no, he's doing his job, Toki, let him cook, let
him, I got it.
I was like, wait a minute, wait a minute.
No, Toki is a professional.
He knows what he's doing.
Wait, I'm...
That's not the reason.
He's trying to defend himself right, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna choose to trust you on this, because we're
going to the healing room right now.
We're going to the healing room.
It's...
Alright.
Alright, the healing center.
I've chosen to trust you on this.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, hey.
Oh, they're just drinking coffee.
That ain't too bad.
They're all healing.
They're just healing right now.
Invite...
Oh, I can invite people to healing center.
All right.
Where do we activate the heals?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Please, I've played these games before.
All right.
I feel like you need a license for this, so I don't know
what I'm doing All right She's been playing video games all
night and has made her back hurt hurty All right I'll leave
it to you then All right, so I do Oh my god, wait, this is
just like that game Wait
Oh my god Wait Wait
What?
No, nothing, nothing, nothing.
Nothing.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
It really...
...
all right just this one no nothing nothing guys nothing
oh no the soothing film actually now i feel even more sore
no i'm so bad oh it's okay we'll treat another girl i i
don't have a license to massage
it's not my fault
I don't have a license to massage!
I've never done this before!
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Guys, I've never done this before.
This is my first time.
No, no, this is my first time.
I've never played any game similar to this before.
Sick.
I Say what we could do another girl with we we have many
women to try out All right here you don't keep me waiting
too long there you go
Where I got this track guys I got this track There you go I
got this track oh I figured it out.
I'm a pro now Look and then we start massaging it There you
go
all right and then we do little massages and then she'll
feel better yeah third time's the charm guys and i take
failing whoa it only it only oh my gosh it only took failing
twice to to to get it right guys we did it we did we healed
her we have we absolutely Successfully healed her guys We
did it okay That was very fun.
I I enjoyed all the mini mini games around the base And like
like I said it
And I helped my girls out now it is time guys It's finally
time We can finally play the actual game.
Does anyone know how to start the...
It should be...
It's a special chapter?
I want to do the...
I want to do the Wintertide Relay.
Where is the Wintertide Relay?
Is it this?
Oh, it's here.
Wait, I just saw it.
Go back?
Oh, go back to the main...
Oh, okay.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I knew I missed it.
Then the event.
Oh, my gosh.
Chain fragments.
Reflection.
Oh, reflection of valley.
Oh, here.
Oh, is it here?
Oh, oh, okay.
So this...
This is the new event based off of the new update blast.
There's 25 days left to play it.
So you can join in and play the new event with Moxer.
So here, right here.
That's it.
Like, the audio people are like, our audio guys were like...
The other idea is like, yes!
Kill the other one!
You're like, fight!
Fight!
Okay, winter...
Winter-tide relay.
Oh, here.
This one.
So we can actually try out New Girl right now.
Oh my god, we get to kill Frosty!
Okay.
Top ladder.
Okay, attempt.
Wait, oh, wait, they killed them already?
Who the- they already killed Frosty?
Good face, Bob.
He's already- I didn't even get dressed to kill Frosty!
All right, I guess what now?
What can we do, guys?
Unfortunately, Frosty is already dead.
Goodbye, Frosty.
He's already he got melted We got we were too busy in the
hot springs God damn it I didn't realize While I was in the
hot springs they were killing Frosty Which one will be fun
to do chat on here Because that was my plan I think I I
waited too long to kill it I think I I think I was I was in
the in the healing room too long, guys.
What is this?
Done.
That's me.
Let's come in.
Wait, is this healing room part two?
You've been working so hard, I made you some coffee.
There's auto?
Oh, wait.
There you go.
Oh.
I don't know if I'm autoing or not.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Star Wish.
Oh, we're going to decorate the trees.
Oh my god.
She's moving.
I'm speed reading.
I'm definitely speed reading right now.
So what they're saying is that they're going to decorate a
tree right now.
And she's talking about Star Wish, which is like Christmas.
But for this world.
For like Snowbray.
And then they're like.
Oh, yeah, Star Wish is coming up right now.
And they're like, don't worry, I got a plan coming in.
So then they're like, here's the plan.
And then they're like, okay, so what we're going to do is
we're going to do all of this for Star Wish.
And then I'm like, that's a great idea.
Let's have a Star Wish.
And I'm like, I'm totally down for this.
And then they're like checking the plan and be like, okay,
we should do this for it.
And then they're like, all right, so we're going to do that.
And then we should tell these people to do this.
And then they're like, yeah, that's cool.
And then now, they're all writing a document because, you
know, you know, government workers, you know, it's like all
bureaucracy.
So they're all inviting the people being like, let's all go
do Starwish stuff, like decorate the Starwish tree and
because it's the holidays.
And then they're like, there.
And then we're decorating the Starwish.
See, I told you that was basically the story.
I told you guys.
I said we were gonna decorate.
Did we decorate the cell?
I told you guys.
Mary Starwish.
I told you.
I wasn't lying about the plot.
Okay, so what could we do?
Other than challenge, because I do want to try out a moxer.
Can we do it in the main story?
Can we play it?
Let's try it.
Or is there like anything we could do to try out like a
challenge thing?
or similar for a co-op battle but there's only me
the fence line zero is fun wait oh it says okay oh my god
didn't okay um i want to use moxer a suit normal oh they're
matchmaking oh has auto maybe i could carry um i want to use
my new girl
Is it her?
Oh, there she is.
Oh, she's level 1.
Okay, guys, give me a sec.
Let's just...
Is there a way to max this out?
Like...
Let's just keep going.
Let's just...
Oh, hold?
Oh, nice.
Okay, I was going to say, am I going to have to click this
forever?
All right, and then...
All right, here you go.
Holy shit, she's strong.
Okay, yeah, nice.
All right, there you go.
Now we can send you in.
All right, we should be good.
Oh, change your gun?
Oh, you're right.
Uh...
How do I change your gun?
Oh, change, there you go.
Where's your gun?
Moxie?
Moxer, where's your gun?
What's your gun called?
What is it?
Is it this or this?
Oh, I didn't get her gun?
Alright, I'm stealing your gun.
Wait, attack!
Okay, I'm stealing your gun.
This is my gun right now.
This is my gun.
Any type of sniper.
Wait, is this a sniper?
Starlift.
Truth.
I assume this is a sniper, right?
this looks like a sniper yeah okay oh it's level 80 already
nice alright let's alright I don't have any weapon modifiers
unlucky alright my sniper now alright lost just six uh max
HP defense uh let's put you in well I can train her too
I'm making sure she's very strong.
Give me a sec.
I need her to be the strongest.
Alright.
And then...
That should be good.
Trade.
There we go.
She's so strong now.
Alright, we got that.
And then...
And it puts you in here.
to wait this is for intelligence medical oh i should put
medical all right trade
all right and then nice oh my god you're me so strong and
then bam all right we get her and this is who are you where
are you i feel like we should just go medical right Jericho
is all support.
Oh, critical damage, amplifier, let's fucking go.
Oh, you're already...
Oh, you got everything already.
Alright.
Oh, wait, I can only do one of each.
Okay, I just realized I can only do one of each.
Alright, equip.
I'll train you too.
Boom!
Trade.
all right there's no way i can die now i'm so tanky now all
right here we go all right we should be good to go wait
unless oh shit okay that's it's okay we should be good to go
is there anything else i can all right let's go straight in
i don't remember how i played but let's go straight in It
should be fine.
Deploy.
Invite.
Did I just swap anything here after?
Let me share.
Oh, yeah, I have to invite a...
No, we don't need to invite anyone.
Alright, here we go.
Wait.
No, we got...
Let's get friends helping.
Who the fuck is?
Billy.
Hey, guys.
I am definite.
Guys, don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, everyone.
I know what I'm doing.
Don't.
Don't worry, everyone.
I definitely know what I'm...
Oh, I forgot to select specialization.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
Oh, I forgot to adjust the sound.
May the world resound with ya, ya, ya.
Um...
Yeah.
Okay, I'll also do that.
We'll all be attackers.
Um...
Yeah, I need to adjust the sound effects by 20, apparently.
Okay.
Um...
They're coming.
Yeah.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, guys, guys, don't worry.
They won't know that.
I need to...
Lower my sense real quick.
okay see I'm helping guys I'm helping look
at that I'm helping see oh it's like it's a tower defense
look at that um I don't know what I did they don't need to
know that.
They don't need to know that.
I think I should have, I think I should have read my
abilities, guys.
All right, that's jump.
What does my E do?
I did something, right?
I think I did something.
Oh, nice.
We have supplies.
Don't worry.
We got this.
We're holding the front lines.
I feel like I should buy stuff.
Man, don't even have to move.
They're not gonna get me.
Here's target has appeared still.
Where?
Oh, here.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
They're not blocks anymore.
Wait, they're real people.
Oh, my God.
They hitbox.
They're so tiny now.
Don't worry, I got this.
Watch this.
Elucir dream.
Oh my god, watch this.
I ulted.
I'm dancing.
Oh!
I did it.
I'm dancing.
I'm still dancing see how they like this your tower is so
healthy boom here's another one
i should really buy stuff okay uh supplies vanguard anytime
your stores oh my gosh i want to buy stuff but the wave
keeps coming before i can boom here's another one
but i have more i'm more don't worry oh sorry i have more Oh
god.
Oh god.
They're getting closer.
Wait, they're dirt?
Wait, they're hitting!
Oh my god, no, they're hitting.
Everything's fine.
I have more turrets?
I could keep pointing up more.
I could just keep spamming it.
No, I can't keep spamming it, guys.
I just realized.
I can't keep spamming it.
I have limited amount.
Let's see how they like this I should head downstairs to
help Wait, I think Altus Drown in the dream
Bloom Um I have a feeling that That didn't do anything I'm
sorry I'm sorry guys I
I don't think Do anything Do you think Do you think Oh, it
buffs my they don't know they don't know guys they don't
know that I didn't know that it just only Buffs my turrets.
They didn't know that I didn't know Guys, I should have read
my abilities before I logged in but they won't know I'm just
a I'm just a little sniper
that I don't know it's okay we just needed we just needed to
survive another wave no they can't hear it there's no way
they hear it there's no way I refuse to believe all right
I'll help out here I'll put turrets
And then I'll stop dancing!
Look, see?
Bada, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, I have yet to buy anything.
I'm too overwhelmed to buy stuff right now.
Oh, my God!
Okay, I'm shooting her.
I'm only shooting her.
it's okay i'm i'm not i'm barely doing any damage to her but
i have shot her though need us to say i have indeed shot her
oh this is very bad this is very bad oh oh it's okay that
that's not gonna kill us that's not gonna we were still five
50 we made it mission completed nothing to worry about
Time to relax together.
Highest shot damage.
Look at that.
I don't know what these numbers mean, but I think the lower
the number, the better.
I assume that's what it means.
Yeah.
It's just like golf.
Guys, it's like golf, guys.
Let's go with that.
Yay!
I think I did really well.
Guys, oh, what do I have?
Can I decorate my wish tree now?
Oh, we have to complete quest.
I don't think we did a single quest, guys.
Wait, there's a...
What mini-game is that?
Someone said there's like a...
There's that mini-game.
I can't say it.
Or what mini-game is that?
Where do we go for that?
Is it in the base?
Not a single quest.
It's back in reflection.
Oh, it's in here.
Which one is it?
Let's optimize.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that is so cute.
Wait, that is so cute.
Oh, I want to beat.
I'll be pure heart.
We're doing a simulation or classic.
difference what's the what's the simulation or class what's
the difference between classic and assimilation assimilation
chat oh okay we'll do classic then uh all right start
matchmaking we gotta get a team all right we got this oh
it's like zombies oh
I see
I've been having a great time
Hi everyone I need Oh I was gonna say Did like someone kick
me out Oh my guys Join me in classic I was like How did it
go down Oh
But a huge shout out to Snowbrick for the sponsor, everyone.
Make sure to check them out.
Click on the link pinned in the chat or the panel or the QR
code or even just exclamation point Snowbrick.
In YouTube, you can get 110 free posts and a free SSR
character, which was Moxer.
He used to get a zombie player earlier.
All right, let's go.
I don't have to play this.
Hello, everyone.
Be careful not to fall.
Use bombs not auto-ers off, but be safe to yourself.
Let the chaos begin.
Okay, bomber fall.
Just don't fall.
Okay.
That should be easy enough.
Oh my god.
They already got the shield.
Coming for you.
Boom.
Oh my god.
I gotta grab the shield.
I don't trust none of you.
Boom.
Oh my god.
Oh.
my god, my shield is already got.
Oh, wait.
Someone.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
So like, if it hits you, you like, okay, I got the shield.
I think the key right now is that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, that was so scary.
Oh, there's so, oh, my gosh.
Oh, the walls are coming.
Okay, I got the shield though.
I'm gonna hold it.
I think that's the key.
I'm okay.
Wait, wait, how am I okay?
Wait, how am I?
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I don't know how.
No!
I'm okay.
I'm...
Because for some reason, I was no longer okay.
I was so lagger okay I don't understand I don't I was
panicking okay okay this time this time it'll work this time
it'll work guys and I will be okay I just kept I don't know
for some reason I saw the spinny thing and I was like that
looks safe looks safe.
I thought I was safe.
It spun, and I was like, I want to touch it.
But it was not a safe wheel.
It was not a safe stick.
Is that crazy?
Isn't that crazy?
It wasn't safe.
Oh my god.
We were so close to 15.
We're hit 14 and then it went back down.
Where are you guys?
Where did all of you guys go?
All right, here we go
We made it Ro ring jump okay Guys wouldn't be why he has all
the oh it's cuz you're all Okay, oh my god.
It's this I'm so bad with this one guys Please let me have
the purple ring guys, please That's all I would I'll grab
that I'm so close to that blue ring Yes, I got it I got the
blue, I got the blue I got the blue Oh my god No, I thought
he was She was gonna miss that She looked like she didn't
know what she's doing No, there's another one Nice Nice
Okay, we got it.
Oh my god, nice, nice.
No one's got this yet.
No one still, no one still hasn't got.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's gonna be another one at this.
Oh, I'll grab this.
Okay.
That's fine.
Nice.
Haha, you missed!
You missed!
Okay, it's fine, that's fine.
We farm the little ones.
No one's farming the little ones.
We'll be okay.
The little ones will take me to victory.
They're all trying to trying to get the big ones.
But slow and steady.
Slow and steady.
Me, bitch.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
I'm the 20.
130 Oh, I'm almost there, I'm almost there, I'm almost there
My bitch!
Yeah!
Watch this Boom!
Complete it!
Slow and steady Slow and steady wins the race That's right,
only 15 left Who's gonna get it?
Who's gonna get it?
Oh, she's still trying to get that blue girl what i think
she has person has to be on mobile yeah no this this looks
like this looks like she's trying to control on mobile right
now but yes this game is available on all on maturity of the
platform not all sorry on majority of platforms iOS android
PCs no this she's she's trying she's trying guys she's she's
all right okay we're doing it all right come on you can make
the jump come on there's still guys come on guys come on
just don't run against the system let it take you let this
take you come on you almost got it broly feel the wheel.
There you go.
Let the wheel take you.
Okay.
Let the wheel guide you.
What?
Oh.
Wait, was that it?
Do I not go to the next round?
Wait, what?
Oh, is it after I pass through, I... That win?
Wait, did I win?
do i go to it oh oh it's only one round oh okay i get it oh
so i was just watching them i thought i was like oh okay
that makes sense i was like wait that got kicked out because
i was too busy laughing at them okay oh so the goal is to
try to get top three i see I see it's like little mini games
I was like did they like banish me because you're like I was
like me I was like yeah that's right all right we'll try
simulation and then we'll look we'll we'll end with a
simulation I'm curious what this one is
I've been having fun
I drank all my water.
I don't know how that happened.
I guess I was really thirsty.
Basically, some people spawn as bad guys and they kill the
good guys and they kill the good guys.
They become a bad guy.
Oh, okay.
I did spill a bit of my water.
I did.
Welcome to the Heimdall Operational Optimization Test.
Don't get assimilated by the hams.
Okay.
Defeat them and survive till the end.
Alright, here I go.
Oh, they know all the hiding spots.
They're pros.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get you.
No!
I'm gonna, I'm gonna get you.
That's right.
Get in here.
Zero.
That's right.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
Sorry, I didn't know.
Guys, when did I hide it accidentally?
When did it happen?
All heroes have been enhanced.
Move.
Grab it fast.
Oh, just when the game started, I got too excited.
Bam!
Oh my god, why are you so tanky?
What?
He is so tanky!
We gotta get him.
I can't believe it.
I started up.
I started off as a...
as a robot.
Where's the last guy?
Where is he?
I'm ready.
I can't find the last guy.
there she is i'm coming for you i'm coming for you that's
right get over here get over here get over here welcome to
the crew welcome where's the last one where are you
oh she's oh that's right we're coming over
Oh, don't worry.
I got the shield.
I'm coming for it.
Boom!
Yeah, it's time to log you in the database.
Simulated four.
They're simulated four of you.
Oh no, donkeys coming.
That's right.
You cannot run me.
I started as a robot too.
I can't believe leave it was fucking timing um but yeah
thank you all for checking out snowbreak with me today that
was a wild ride like i said it's been a very long time i
think when the game first launched i'm pretty sure uh when
the game first launched um was the last time i played
snowbreak so a lot has changed a lot has changed but there's
like it feels like there's a lot more content there's Um, I
feel like the character animations and the character 3D
models are are insane There is 100% rate up for limited
characters too and um Um, there's high quality 3D outfits
and character interactions with low cost there's so many
things you can do basically There's also for new players for
new players.
They do have a prologue.
They have a new prologue that they put in there That helps
new players easily catch up.
So, you know, you want to catch up with the story and stuff.
They do have prologue for it, so there's no FOMO for anyone.
And it is the only 3D waifu shooter.
So it combines relaxing gunplay, engaging story, and casual
accessibility.
It is very, very accessible, definitely for sure.
Also, apparently, daily task takes up to one minute, And all
upgrade resources are 100% free to earn so you can be a free
to player free to play player Um, so you don't have to spend
no spending required um and and Um, if you click on the link
pinned in my chat my panel my QR code right here, you know
look at that QR code
All right Um, you can get up to 110 free pulls and a free
SSR character which is moxer uh which we showcase there the
cat girl um so lots of notice will be free to change
starting january which was yesterday yay so again huge shout
out and thank you to snowbreak for the sponsor guys um that
was wild that was a that's been a wild sponsor but it's been
also really fun huge So exclamation point snowbreak if you
want to try out the game yourself.
I'm gonna head out now I want this download to be faster
Don't worry when you're in you have all the time in the
world to spend with your wife Here's a recommendation for
you make sure to go to the healing rooms Andrea
Drew Bird, thank you for the, Drew Bird, Vivisle, thank you
for the Twitch Prime, thank you, thank you everyone for the
Prime subs, for the subscriptions, for follows, bitties,
donations, thank you again, thank you for all the raids,
everyone.
I'm thinking of checking the stream out.
For those who are new here, my name is Dokey Bird.
I'm usually on YouTube, so please check me out on YouTube.
If you wanna watch more of my main content, Sometimes
whenever I'm on Twitch, it's usually when I'm sponsored or
I'm doing something that's not on my schedule.
So please follow me on Twitter.
Because on Twitter, I usually tweet out whenever I'm going
to be streaming on Twitch.
If you want to support me via other means, feel free to
check out my merch, exclamation point merch.
So check me out on my socials and my merch website.
It's a great way to support me and the stream.
I'm going to head off now.
As always, I'm going to grab some dinner.
I'm fucking starving.
now after all that and more water um as always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get
that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed
guys you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye